my next recipe is a proper British
classic that's super simple to cook and
costs next to nothing a delicious apple
crumble
crumbles are the perfect way to use
fruit when it's in season there's lots
of it about it's nice and cheap but most
importantly the fruits at its absolute
best
[Music]
first off I'm going to make a really
nice light caramel pan on nice and low
great two apples
[Music]
this helps to almost sort of pure the
Apple so much quicker there's a lot of
flavor in the skin so don't worry about
peeling the fruit whether it's pears
plums peaches flavors in the skin
[Music]
start the camera a couple of tablespoons
of sugar the sugar helps to get rid of
the tartness in the Apple a touch
cinnamon that starts to make it a little
spicy open up your vanilla and just
scrape out all those seeds now this just
makes it light and fragrant all those
seeds in to the Sugar We're making
caramel be patient and always swirl the
dish instead of stirring it
when the sugar goes Brown add the Apple
starts to sort of cool down the caramel
but it gives it a really nice sort of
caramelized puree apples almost
disintegrating
smells incredible
and the gas down
slice up two apples it's a crumble
That's Got No Frills straightforward
they're faffing around no peeling on the
skin I want them to sort of stand out
from the camera
apples in
now there's nice thick chunks of Apple
sort of almost bedding itself into the
puree
dried cranberries gives it that nice
sort of shock in the texture
sweet
chewy I want it to sort of taste zesty
spicy so sit the lemon zest on top of
your apples and cranberry fresh lemon
juice over and that just gives that
extra acidic kick takes the Cranberries
the apples the caramel and the cinnamon
to another level turn the gas off
that says let's concentrate on the
crumble flowering
a couple of tablespoons of Demerol sugar
sugar helps to get the topping nice and
crispy
batter in
give that a nice little rub what we're
looking for is like a
breadcrumb mixture lightly season it
with a touch of cinnamon
and the dimmer our sugar sort of helps
to get a nice fine crumble mix and it
stops the butter from sort of melting in
that flour so that's the basic crumble
mix but I'm not finished yet muesli
two-thirds crumble
one third muesli mix that in if you
haven't got muesli then crunchy granola
works brilliantly too lovely
now start off in the center
and work your way around
I want the crispiness on the top the
puree on the bottom of the caramel and
then the texture in the center a good
tip
turn the gas back on I want it bubbling
before it goes in the oven because then
you just got to cook the top so as soon
as you see that caramel starting to
Bubble down the side in she goes let's
go
all right
bake it 200 degrees Celsius for 12 to 14
minutes until golden brown
smells amazing
[Music]
still bubbling
and look at it a delicious but very
simple crumble with apples at their
absolute best beautiful
and on for the stuffing
it's a saddle of lamb basically a sort
of Rolls-Royce cut perfectly shaped and
it suits stuffing to an absolute tea but
the stuffing finely chop an onion
garlic nice thin slices
oil in
onions and garlic in
[Music]
salt
and pepper make sure the stuffing is
beautifully seasoned so it helps to
season the inside of the lamb now we've
got the color on those onions I'm going
to throw in some pine nuts that helps to
give a bit of a texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting
spinach in and just lay the spinach over
the pine nuts it looks like a lot of
spinach that's going to condense and
disappear almost instantly
it's more flavors finish when you saute
it as opposed to steaming it or boiling
it gas off look at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
bread crumbs crumpled feta over the
spinach feta cheese adds a beautifully
salty sharp and creamy flavor
what this does
it brings that stuffing together
now
open up the lamb keep those little
fillets to the side that's the channel
that we want to stuff so I want to just
open that up a little bit there salt
and pepper lightly
if you forward stuffing in
we're going to season it with
Sumo sumac is a wonderful lemony spice
that goes brilliantly with lamb and you
can get it in most big supermarkets and
I sort of cuts through that thick Rich
sweetness of the Lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon if you're preparing this
for the day ahead then let the stuffing
cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it someone's going to
squeeze out so load up the ends
take these Beauties these little fillets
and just support that stuffing and sort
of increase that beautiful tunnel and
then from there
over there
and bring that towards you and then roll
like I said some of the stuff is going
to come out
now just tie it first off around the
side and don't worry about some flash
which is not just tie it
one in the middle
you can get butcher string from your
local butcher or at cookware shops I got
two ties
go too tight it just forces all that
stuffing out of the Lamb when it's in
the oven
nice
now I want to season the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but get your tray onto the
gas oil in
get it really nicely colored
none of your stuffing's coming out of
the sides really important
look at that color beautiful does kick
start the roasting process
gas off into the oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink you want your lamb
[Music]
the lamb out of the fat to rest resting
it raised up in the tin will stop it
cooking but not cool it down too quickly
and means you won't lose any of those
lovely juices next I'm making a simple
but sophisticated accompaniment for the
lamb top and tell the Cucumber
peel it
cut the Cucumber into three and just
core take out all that it's just sort of
watery seedium it spoils the flavor
sliced cucumber
cucumber in
really nice way of making a cheap and
cheerful cucumber look glamorous we're
going to dress that cucumber with a nice
fresh yogurt a couple of tablespoons
next some fresh mint dressing Touch of
salt
Touch of pepper
and then pomegranate molasses
that just swings it up finish that with
lemon
mix that up
it's rested
carefully take off the string
and then just gently pull them back
the straight edge knife is going to cut
through that crispy fat on the outside
instantly I tied it purposely so I can
guess
my portion control from the lines hold
it nice and firmly look at your line
where the string was
and look
and this one is going to be amazing
lay and down
just in those two slices there it proves
that stuffing Meats
is for special occasions because that is
a saddle of lamb at its absolute best
stuffing meats and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor Dimension too once
you've mastered the technique you'll be
able to turn out dishes that will
guarantee you'll have an unforgettable
feast
foreign